INTERVIEWER: Thank
you, thank you Holly.
And welcome, Tamara.
We're so excited to
have you here today.
TAMARA MELLON: I'm
excited to be here.
INTERVIEWER: So before
we jump into it,
I have to call out the
elephant in the room.
TAMARA MELLON: OK.
INTERVIEWER: I am only
wearing one Jimmy Choo shoe.
I wanted to wear two, but one
was really all I could muster.
Have you ever been interviewed
by someone only wearing
one shoe?
TAMARA MELLON: No I haven't.
This is a new experience.
INTERVIEWER: OK, hopefully
we can make it a great one.
So your new book,
"In My Issues,"
is a very honest memoir,
a tell-all if you will.
As Holly mentioned about your
early career at British "Vogue"
through to co-founding
Jimmy Choo,
and then exiting the
company and really turning
a new leaf in your life.
So why now?
What prompted you to
write the book now?
TAMARA MELLON: Well,
starting a new chapter,
I thought it was a great
way to close one chapter
and enter a new one.
And I also thought, no one's
going to really believe
what was really going on behind
the scenes at Jimmy Choo.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah, there's
some pretty salacious stories
there-- really, really exciting
and challenging, certainly.
So you're somewhat of a
self-taught business women.
In the book, you talk about
your father's influence.
Tamara's father, for those
of you that don't know,
co-founded Vidal Sassoon.
So, a very savvy businessman
in his own right.
But you talk about how
he offered you insights
and guidance, but a great
deal of your learning
was through trial and error.
So for example your
experience with private equity
deals and your troubles there.
So for those of us
in the audience who
have an entrepreneurial
bent, or perhaps
want to start our own companies,
what advice do you have?
TAMARA MELLON: Well when I set
out, when I founded Jimmy Choo,
you know obviously my goal
was to make beautiful shoes.
I didn't realize that I'd be
getting into the private equity
world.
And I entered it
because Jimmy decided
to sell his shares in 2001.
And obviously he had a right to
sell them to whomever wanted.
And that's how private equity
came into the business.
So I had to learn very quickly.
I was dealing with investment
bankers, the financial world,
and so it was really
a self-education.
INTERVIEWER: Definitely.
And something you
just mentioned,
going through the
business world,
I imagine that sometimes it felt
very much like a man's world.
What were the
challenges that you
found in being a woman in
this sometimes man's world?
TAMARA MELLON: It was-- yeah,
I faced things which I really
didn't expect to face
in today's world.
Very much as a woman, you still
get diminished and discounted.
Your Opinions are
very much discounted.
And strangely enough
I ended up being
on the board of Jimmy
Choo with 10 men.
And I was the only woman, which
is sort of illogical, really,
if you think about it.
And also I was dealing
with unequal pay.
So discovering all these
things on my journey
was also part of why
I wrote the book.
Because I wanted to really
address a lot of these issues.
And things I noticed
about women's behavior
in the workplace compared
to men was very different.
And I wanted to address
that in the book as well.
INTERVIEWER:
Fantastic, yes there's
definitely a theme of
empowerment as a woman,
as a businesswomen in the book.
You also have some
fantastic charitable efforts
that we'd love to
hear more about.
TAMARA MELLON: Well I'm going
to be starting a foundation when
the Tamara Mellon brand.
And its to work
on women's rights,
for gender discrimination
and equal pay
and also dealing with
the sex-slave trade.
INTERVIEWER: Wonderful.
Wonderful.
You became something
of a celebrity
during the course of
running Jimmy Choo shoes.
A funny out take from
your book, which I loved,
someone came up to you and
asked for your autograph
on their receipt from their
first pair of Jimmy Choo shoes.
So a great indicator of this
fan base that you created.
So I'd love to hear a little
bit more about that experience,
and how you really leveraged
it to build the brand.
TAMARA MELLON: What's
important for a brand,
particularly starting
off, is that you
have someone that embodies the
brand, and a story to tell,
and someone that they can
buy in to, or identify with.
So really, if you think
about most big brands,
they have a
personality attached.
And you buy into that person.
You buy the story
they're telling.
Because when you're
also creating a brand,
you're creating a woman.
So it's a fancy
in my head, maybe,
about the woman I want to be.
And maybe other women
want to be that as well.
So when you're creating the
product, when you're creating--
it's one woman, it's her world.
And it's a vision.
INTERVIEWER: And you really
lived that life to a degree.
TAMARA MELLON: And then I ended
up-- I didn't expect that.
But then when we realized
that journalists wanted
to do interviews
about the company,
that was really the
only one who could do it
because I was
creating the product
and I was running the
operations of the business.
So that really I
was the only one
that could speak to what was
going on in the business.
So it happened to me
by default, really.
And then once you're
in the limelight,
then people become fascinated
with your personal life
and they become sort of--
so it all kind of opens up.
INTERVIEWER: Right.
So you talked a little bit about
really understanding this woman
that you're catering
to and her aesthetic.
With the launch of your need
collection, the Tamara Mellon
Namesake Collection,
which is coming out very,
very soon-- it includes
ready-to-wear accessories,
handbags, and more.
What type of woman
are you designing for?
You mentioned a lot that you
inject your own personal DNA,
you know, being a working
mother, as well as
a globetrotter,
being very modern.
These are aspects that we've
seen in the Jimmy Choo line.
Are they things that we'll also
see in the Tamara Mellon line?
TAMARA MELLON: Definitely
it follows with me
because it's my DNA.
But in a very modern way.
The most exciting thing
with the new brand
was starting with a clean slate.
And thinking about the
woman today, particularly
with the business model.
That's very different.
Of our psychology and how
we want to shop today.
Because the world has changed
since I started Jimmy Choo.
We're living in a
very different world.
INTERVIEWER: Right, right.
Well nobody's a bigger digital
enthusiast than we are.
And the way you're using
digital to launch your new brand
is very, very interesting.
You're really turning the
traditional model on its head.
So you're leading with digital.
The e-commerce platform
is going to be pretty much
the primary outlet for this
brand with brick and mortar
locations coming
up later next year.
Can you tell us a little
bit about that strategy?
TAMARA MELLON: It's-- when
I looked at the way we live
today, what happens is a fashion
show goes up online as soon
as it happens.
And everybody sees it.
And that never used to happen.
Only the press and buyers
would see the fashion show.
And the customer
would see the product
when it was in a magazine
and went into a store.
So as a customer, we're looking
at that product for six months
before it gets into the store.
So by the time it's the shop
floor, we're a bit like,
oh god, I've over it now.
I've looked at it for too long.
And we want the next new thing.
And also the world
is-- we're buying
things in the wrong season
because the department
stores have really pushed
to get things on the floor
early so they can sell it.
They can beat their customers,
which means we've ended up with
coats on the floor in July,
spring/ summer dresses going
in in January.
Who wants to but that?
I don't want a coat in July.
And I don't know any woman
that wants to do that.
Or who can even
think about a product
that they're going to
wear in four months time.
You want to buy
something now and you
want to wear it tomorrow.
So I have a business
model that is seasonless.
And it goes into stores monthly.
And it's a different
fashion concept every month.
But it's what you're going to
want to wear in that month.
INTERVIEWER:
Interesting, interesting.
And how are you
finding that this
is being received in
the fashion industry?
Because again, this is
not the traditional model.
I don't know why
you're the first person
to do this because it
makes so much sense.
But I'm wondering how
you found the reception.
TAMARA MELLON: The customer
is clear and loud, yes.
I mean I love communicating
with my customers
on Twitter and Instagram.
And the messages
I'm getting back
is thank god someone's
finally doing this.
This is what we want.
So the customer is there.
The industry, we're
pushing them a little bit
to get on board with it.
Department store, you
know-- they bought it.
We're going to be in Bergdorf's,
Nieman's, and Net-a-Porter.
Net-a-Porter is actually there.
They're also pushing
designers to do it.
But the traditional
bricks-and-mortar department
stores are worried about, well
if you have new product going
in January when all our
autumn/winter is on sale, how's
it going to look on the floor?
How's the customer
going to react?
But I'm pushing,
and I'm just saying,
you know what, just
test the customer
because I know it's
what she wants.
So I think once they see
the customer's response,
then they'll really
get behind it.
INTERVIEWER: So this
isn't the first time
you've pushed the envelope.
With Jimmy Choo, you definitely
pushed the creative envelope
and launched new products.
What was your favorite
throughout your time
being there?
Was there a specific
collection or project
you worked on that comes to
mind as being a favorite?
TAMARA MELLON: Oh I have a
lot of babies from Jimmy Choo.
But I would say
my favorite things
are animal prints, leopard
prints, zebra, I love fringe,
studs, glitter.
So if you see a product with any
of those things on, you know--
INTERVIEWER: A little
bit of rock 'n roll, OK.
So just going back to
your new collection,
the way it's being
released, this
puts an even larger
importance on staying ahead
of trend, which is something
that fashion brands grapple
with all the time.
How do you manage to
say ahead of trends?
TAMARA MELLON: Well a
normal fashion brand designs
a year ahead.
And it's often what you
want in you life then.
But you've got to
wait a year for it.
It's very frustrating.
So now I can design something.
And I can have it on the shop
floor three months later.
So from design, from a
sketch, to on shop floor,
it's a much shorter window.
So I can really gauge the
temperature of the customer
and what we're
feeling and what we
want right then in that moment.
INTERVIEWER: OK, OK.
So you are all about
taking on challenges
and reinventing
yourself to a degree.
What's next for you?
TAMARA MELLON: Next?
I've hardly started
this one yet.
INTERVIEWER: Well
in your book-- I'm
sure you guys will
all enjoy reading it--
but Tamara takes on
challenge after challenge,
often at the same very time.
So while you were
working on Jimmy Choo,
you also started
reinventing Houston.
TAMARA MELLON: Yes.
INTERVIEWER: And so it
wouldn't be out of character
for you to take on multiple
projects at the time.
But I could
completely understand
if a vacation was what you
needed in the near future.
TAMARA MELLON: You're
absolutely right actually.
While I was writing the
book, launching a new brand,
I decided to renovate my
apartment at the same time.
INTERVIEWER: Yes.
TAMARA MELLON: So yeah.
INTERVIEWER: And you
have a young daughter
Minty Melon whose name I'm
very jealous of-- that's
the best name ever.
And you're splitting your
time between New York
are London as well.
TAMARA MELLON: And yeah, I
have a design studio in Paris
and here in New York.
All my shoes and bags are
manufactured in Italy.
I'm working with
the same factories
that I've worked
with for 15 years.
So it's a pure luxury product.
But what I'm doing is I'm going
to take a smaller margin so I
can deliver an amazing product
to my customer at a more
affordable price point.
And then also the
ready-to-wear is--
what I've done with
the pricing is actually
an interesting hybrid.
Because the ready-to-wear
dress is about $800,
a skirt is $600, which is
a contemporary price point.
It's not a pure designer luxury.
If you had a brand
at that price point,
you'd normally find
the shoes at $300.
INTERVIEWER: Right.
TAMARA MELLON: But
my shoes are higher
because they're pure luxury.
So I have high contemporary
clothing, and pure luxury shoes
and bags.
INTERVIEWER: Is there
a brand in the luxury
space or the
contemporary market,
or even unrelated,
that you think
is doing a really great job
of establishing themselves
as a brand but also activating
themselves digitally?
TAMARA MELLON: Burberry has been
a real pioneer in that area.
And I'm really working
with social media today.
Because for me also
it's different from when
I started Jimmy Choo.
We didn't have social media.
And times have changed.
And just having that direct
communication with the customer
is the most important
thing today.
When I started Jimmy Choo,
there was a new wave.
Accessories where exploding.
And magazines realize that
if they put an actress
on the cover, their
readership went up.
So the whole celebrity and
fashion relationship started.
And that's why I took
Jimmy Choo to the Oscars
within the first two
years of business.
But today, it's
very different now.
Now it's direct the customer.
Is communicating with them
on Instagram, on Twitter,
on things like YouTube, Android.
All these get you
direct communication,
which is what they want now.
INTERVIEWER: Do you
find that there's
a challenge between asserting
yourself as a luxury brand
but also having that
two-way communication,
because that's certainly a lot
of what we hear in the luxury
sector, that you want
to establish yourself
as being elite and sophisticated
and top-of-market, but also
approachable and
someone that you
can communicate with as a brand.
So do you have any strategy
in terms of social media
and how you're
going to structure
that for the Tamara Mellon line?
TAMARA MELLON: I
think that being elite
is an old-fashioned view.
I think you can be
absolutely luxury
and still communicate
with your customer.
So, no I'm direct all the
time, myself talking with them.
And I don't think designers
should sit in their ivory tower
and not communicate
with their customer.
INTERVIEWER: Right,
you mentioned Twitter.
Is your favorite social
media platform right now?
TAMARA MELLON: I like Instagram.
Yeah, Instagram is a really fun.
And now you can put little
videos out, which is great.
Yeah, so Twitter, Instagram.
We still do pretty
much everything.
INTERVIEWER: Wonderful.
Wonderful.
Well thank you so much for
sharing all this with us.
We love your new book.
Again it's at the back if anyone
would like to pick up a copy.
I'd love to turn
it to the audience
and ask if you guys have
any questions, anything
we haven't touched on.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
TAMARA MELLON: In November.
Yeah, it'll be in Bergdorf's,
Nieman's and Net-a-Porter
and Harrod's in London in case
anyone's there in November.
AUDIENCE: I have one.
You mentioned, while you
were in your discussion,
that at one point you were
one woman out an entire board
of all men, especially
for products
that are targeted towards women.
How did you feel
in those moments?
And was there ever a time where
you had to strongly advocated
particularly from like
a female perspective?
TAMARA MELLON: The
difficult thing
was that all the men on my board
were from the private equity
industry.
So your interests are
not really always aligned
with their interests.
They're really looking at just
getting [INAUDIBLE] profits up
so they can sell.
They want to come in and
out as quickly as they can.
And as a founder,
you really care
about the quality of the
product, the people working
in the business.
And also, what's very difficult
for them, because it's not
tangible, is it's an
emotional business.
It's an emotional
connection with the product.
So you could predict
something that's
going to sell in the
future but they may not
have the confidence to put the
money behind it because they
don't understand why.
But it's just an
emotional connection.
INTERVIEWER: So I have one
last question before we wrap.
You share with us so
many personal stories
in "In My Shoes," really
difficult things that you went
through your childhood,
in your adult life.
And something that really shines
through as you read the book
is how resilient you are.
And that you use these
tumultuous experiences really
to become a stronger person.
And that's something
that led you
through even to your
business career.
How did you manage to do that?
Because I think that's
something that we as people
struggle with.
And you've done an amazing job
at just growing and becoming
even stronger through
those difficult times.
TAMARA MELLON: Well
part of it really
is growing up in
an alcoholic home.
It actually-- the
only benefit, you
have a very high
tolerance level for abuse,
or dealing with
difficult situations
because you're used to it.
Other than that, and
then knowing really it's
believing in yourself.
You've just got to
believe in yourself.
And passion.
You've got to keep
following your passion.
I always say, passion
is the number one thing.
Once you have that,
everything else follows.
But I think because
I was so passionate
about the product,
and that company,
it ran through my veins like
the blood runs through my veins,
that I kept fighting for it.
INTERVIEWER: OK, well
thank you so much again.
It was a pleasure
having you here.
Best of luck with the new
collection and everything else.
I'm sure we'll hear
about something else
that you're launching very soon.
TAMARA MELLON: Thank you,
thanks for having me.
INTERVIEWER: Thank you so much.